jacques chirac en israël un voyage
important quand on sait que la france
est impliquée dans plusieurs conflits
régionaux ont laine palestiniens le
liban et la guerre iran irak
quelle place pour la femme dans la
hiérarchie de l'église catholique le
synode des évêques qui a répondu non aux
femmes prêtent invités de ce journal le
cardinal lustiger
chine rajeunissement à la tête du pays
les plus de 80 ans s'en vont y compris
le numéro un des miens au film et qui
lui continuera sans doute à diriger la
réforme économique en coulisses
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel carton marcel fontaine
jean paul kauffmann
jean louis normandin d'antenne 2 et
roger auque les otages français au liban
n'ont toujours pas été libérés
madame monsieur bonsoir comme le veut la
tradition le pape jean paul ii a
aujourd'hui célébré la messe dans un
cimetière de rome à l'occasion de la
toussaint la fête de tous les saints
mais les hasards du calendrier religieux
nous offre la possibilité d'ouvrir ce
soir un dossier qui traite d'un
véritable phénomène de société comme il
est convenu de dire aujourd'hui
puisqu'il s'agit de la place des femmes
dans l'église catholique le synode qui
vient de se terminer réunissait à rome
les principaux responsables de la
hiérarchie du vatican est une question
leur a été posée les femmes
peuvent-elles accéder à des postes de
responsabilité comme la prêtrise voire
plus non ont répondu les évêques
contrairement donc à la religion
protestante par exemple qui ordonne des
femmes pasteurs l'église catholique
reste donc principalement une affaire
d'hommes mais après tout cette volonté
qu indiquent les sondages de voir les
femmes prendre une place du conséquente
dans la hiérarchie de l'église n'est
elle pas surtout extérieur eh bien c'est
ce qu'on peut se demander en regardant
ce reportage de jean claude dari
ces cinq religieuses constituent le
conseil général des soeurs de saint
vincent de paul c'est à dire le petit
groupe qui dirige l'institut religieux
numériquement le plus important de
l'église catholique trente deux mille
femmes trente deux mille femmes qui ont
choisi par idéal d'être disponible et
d'être placés et déplacer sans réticence
et volontiers partout où on les envoie
au fait mine de rien vous avez un
pouvoir gigantesque effectivement nous
prouvons au niveau du conseil général
décidé ensemble que l'emplacement
peut-être fait et est même assez loin
mais je peux dire que ça se fait
toujours en coresponsabilité et jamais
100 classeurs soit vraiment consentante
on ne se penche de dames chez nous qu'on
ne dépasse pas les pieds comme ça
madame la responsable des soeurs de
saint vincent de paul une femme qu'à
l'air tout à fait à l'aise dans des
fonctions qu'elle conçoit comme un
service un service où dit-elle elle
réalise sans problème sa vocation de
femmes et deux chrétiennes
autre climat autres options ce que l'on
découvre ici a fait scandale aux
etats-unis en 1979 une religieuse
manifestement plus contestatrice que la
précédente a décidé elle de jouer le
tout pour le tout et de demander au pape
en visite là-bas que les femmes soit
ordonnée évêque
ce qui est le plus important à propos de
l'ordination c'est son lien avec le
pouvoir de décision car à moins d'être
ordonné un individu n'a pas accès aux
instances de décision donc 1 heure
actuelle les femmes sont exclues de ces
instances au sein de l'église dont vous
aimeriez être évêque ne pourquoi papa
j'aimerais que les femmes et accès à
cette fonction de même que les hommes ce
qui me concerne ce n'est pas ma vocation
mais j'aimerais voir des femmes alors de
l'élection des prochains satcom
électrices et comme candidat autrefois
il n'y avait pas de médecin femme n'y
avait pas d'avocat femmes il n'y avait
pas d'ingénieur femmes aujourd'hui elle
est médecin femme les ingénieurs femmes
et c'est bon pourquoi pourquoi est ce
que dans l'église ça pourrait pas être
la même chose
nous en avons six la compagnie
d'ailleurs aussi pour qu'on en l'église
ou alors là je vous avoue que je vais
tenter demain matin pour moi
35e voyages à l'étranger je vois les
serres de tous les pays du monde entier
et bien jamais des questions cet ordre
m'ont été posées par aucune de mes
soeurs deux opinions deux options qui
partage la communauté catholique de
toute façon les femmes sont de plus en
plus nombreuses à assumer bien des
tâches qui incombaient autrefois aux
prêtres seront ordonnés un jour 56 % des
catholiques y serait favorable
à l'or ont bien l'entendre dans ce
sondage 56% des catholiques favorable à
l'ordination des femmes comme prête à
cette question j'aurais tout de suite la
poser à monseigneur lustiger qui en ce
soir de tout ça nous allons parler
ensuite est avec nous en direct quelque
part dans paris à la gare saint lazare
en plein coeur de la ville alors
monseigneur pourquoi le synode a dit non
à une place plus conséquent dans la
hiérarchie j'ai bien dit dans la
hiérarchie des femmes dans l'église
catholique parce que être prête c'est
une question de pouvoir ni une question
de métier c'est un sacrement et c'est
lié à la conception même que nous avons
du rôle du prêtre alors je peux pas en
dire plus j'étais pas au synode il y
avait des femmes qui étaient les cl
qu'il faudrait interviewé là dessus si
vous voulez pour moi en ce soir de tout
ça vous savez que aujourd'hui c'est
les chrétiens la fête de tous les saints
la foule immense lecture que le papa lui
ce matin que j'ai lu moi même à l'open
de paris où des cris l'avenir l'avenir
c'est une foule je cite la taxe 1 une
foule immense de toutes races nation
langue peuple tribut que personne ne
pouvait compter et ça c'est l'ex et
demain nous prions pour les morts alors
c'est pourquoi je vous ai demandé de jeu
des rendez vous à la gare saint lazare
non et bien lisse à whisky 106 à leur
égard en tout cas oui si son égard car
les salles et voilà
et voilà c'est ces gens là vous voyez
personne ne connaît personne ne me
reconnaît leur tête mais voilà avec quoi
on fait les seins alors jugé antoine
voulons voir justement merci pour moi en
tout cas apparemment ces musiques en
tous cas on ne sait jamais on ne sait
jamais monseigneur lustiger justement
dans le siècle dans lequel nous vivons
cette fin du xxème siècle ou où tout est
matérielle ou toutes les vertus sont son
son matériel est ce qu'on aura encore
l'occasion à votre avis de canaliser
encore beaucoup de saints est ce qu'on
peut encore vivre en état de santé dans
notre époque
écoutez on passe son temps à canoniser
j'étais à rome ya trois semaines pour la
canonisation d'un jeu 6 tu n'as jeune
ouvrier qui est mort en déportation il
avait 22 ans quand il est mort pendant
la guerre dans un camp de concentration
c'était un ouvrier qu'il faudra et
chaque chaque dimanche presque le pape
canoniste d'autres gens des laïcs des
hommes des femmes et la fête
d'aujourd'hui c'est que c'est pas les
saints connus c'est pas les seins
célèbre ses dessins ordinaire est à mon
sens le disait que vous étiez emmené
propre matériel nous sommes ce soir ce
que je pense c'est que dans cette gare
saint lazare il ya tant de gens qui
parce qu'ils se regardent pas qu'ils se
voient pas qu'ils passent sans se
connaître et bien
moi j'aime voir une foule
non pas parce qu'on s'y perd mais parce
que je devine derrière des visages des
secrets et ses secrets c'est que chacun
est très précieux et que ces hommes et
ces femmes sont pas des chiens vous
comprenez alors dernière question
monseigneur lustiger when i tout à
l'heure que les gens qui étaient autour
de vous moi par exemple ou vian devenir
des ça parce que ce dont je vous
remercie mais moi je pensais que les
fins d'après les écritures étaient des
gens parfaits toute leur vie dans un an
les ça vous savez ce que celle ci n'en
pauvres gens qui acceptent de ce pc mais
par dieu qui répondent à dieu c'est
comme quelqu'un qui nous prend la main
qui vous tire celui qui vous tire ses
dieux un sein c'est d'abord qu'elle
n'est pas quelqu'un de parfait c'est
quelqu'un qui répond à l'amour de dieu
et on fait des seins avec des pêcheurs
au fait des seins avec des pauvres gens
c'est ça la force du christianisme merci
oui dit les héros les héros ils se
conduisent dans la vie avec beaucoup de
force mais les cinq peuvent être faible
et c'est une vertu aussi
merci monseigneur
la politique maintenant avec un voyage
le premier ministre monsieur jacques
chirac est arrivé cet après midi à
tel-aviv pour un voyage officiel en
israël avant lui le président françois
mitterrand a déjà fait le voyage mais
c'est la première fois qu'un chef de
gouvernement français en exercice se
rend à jérusalem les voyages de
responsables français dans ce pays avec
lequel nous entretenons des relations
souvent passionnées pour ne pas dire
plus ne se présente jamais comme des
visites de routine ou strictement
protocolaire georges mortels
monsieur chirac était venu ici en 1984
comme maire de paris mais depuis
qu'israël existe c'est à dire depuis
près de 40 ans c'est la première fois
qu'un premier ministre français est reçu
à jérusalem
le juge chirac apparaît à ses auditeurs
de la paix nécessaire au proche-orient -
que quiconque la france que tant
d'affinités et de liens traditionnels
porte vers votre pays et ceux de la
région ne peut rester indifférente à
cette aspiration est essentielle elle
entend continuer l'exercice patient
obstiné difficile qui vise à apaiser les
tensions à rétablir entre les peuples
des relations normales
monsieur shamir le premier ministre
israélien a salué en monsieur chirac un
ami d'israël et l'effet de ces
conversations devrait être une
coopération renforcée notamment dans le
domaine scientifique et culturel
ce voyage marque les bonnes relations
qui existent maintenant entre paris
israël des relations longtemps
difficiles mais qui ont commencé à
s'améliorer avec la visite ici de
monsieur mitterrand en 1982 et cela même
si la france garde ses amitiés arabe et
sa politique arabe et en ce qui concerne
plus personnellement monsieur chirac
cette visite marque aussi l'amélioration
des rapports entre les gaullistes et
israël après ces longues années de
froideur qui ont suivi 1967 et les
sanctions prises par le général de
gaulle à la suite de la guerre des six
jours voilà est en ce moment même
monsieur jacques chirac au cours d'un
déjeuner officiel un dîner officiel vous
exactement est en train de firme est ce
qu'il laissait déjà entendre dans ce
reportage à propos du problème
palestinien monsieur chirac vient de
déclarer en effet dans ce discours qu'il
fait en ce moment même que israël était
attaché aux valeurs démocratiques et que
l'attachement de ce pays aux valeurs
démocratiques était si fort qu israël ne
serait plus tout à fait israël s'il ne
reconnaissait pas à autrui le droit de
choisir son propre destin et monsieur
chirac enchaîne le droit à l'existence
et à la sécurité d'israël doit être
garantie sans ambiguïté mais il faut
aussi que soient reconnus et puisse
s'exercer le droit du peuple palestinien
à déterminer et assurer son avenir une
phrase que nous aurons bien sûr
l'occasion de commenter dans nos
prochaines éditions et peut-être même
dès demain matin dans les quatre vérités
au cours de télématin puisque christian
morin reçoit recevra le premier ministre
israélien monsieur itzhak shamir et
puisque je suis dans la région une
dépêche qui est arrivé aussi au début de
ce journal à propos de la guerre du
golfe il y à une visite en ce moment à
téhéran du premier vice ministre
soviétique des affaires étrangères et à
l'issue de cette visite un communiqué a
été publié indiquant et c'est
intéressant l'iran considère
positivement la proposition faite par
l'union soviétique de force navale des
nations unies dans le golfe remplaçants
les différentes marines qui séjourne
actuellement
la politique française maintenant cette
politique française se présente en ce
moment comme un sport qui ressemblerait
volley ball on sent voyons ce renvoi des
affaires mais à droite comme à gauche
les arguments passe souvent il faut bien
le dire en dessous du fil ainsi la
dernière en date la sphère lüscher que
nous avons longuement développé hier
soir je vous en rappelle les principaux
points il s'agit d'une société société
d'armement françaises qui souffrent
gouvernement de la gauche entre 82 et 86
aurait vendu des armements des munitions
à l'iran et cela malgré l'embarras et
pour couronner le tout le magazine le
point crois pouvoir affirmer qu'une
partie des bénéfices auraient alimenté
les caisses du parti socialiste alors
aujourd'hui les principaux responsables
du ps monte au filet relayer il faut
remarquer par des hommes de la majorité
comme claude labbé ou charles millon qui
se rejoignent sur un point ils disent
arrêtons de patauger dans la boue car
nous serons tous finalement éclaboussé
olivier l'air sur les revenus ministre
de la défense au moment des faits
je remarque que depuis quelque temps
comme ça que je suis moi que lui moi et
on ressort des histoires
il rend
exportations dames et ces voix là dessus
vous savez je suis de marne
je n'ai pas l'ombre et de là mais
je n'ai pas à me justifier est ce que
j'ai une tête à vendre des arts
andré laignel trésorier du parti
socialiste le ps n'a jamais reçu un seul
centime provenant de la sphère lüscher
le ps n'était en rien concerné par cette
affaire
louis mermaz ancien président de
l'assemblée nationale comment se fait-il
qu avait quinze mois de retard cette
affaire si à refaire il ya eu sorte web
non par son nez à la veille des
élections présidentielles est ce qu'on
va laisser la vie politique devenir un
véritable cloaque en lequel on va se
jeter à la tête des affaires cela n'est
pas possible
roland dumas ancien ministre des
relations extérieures il s'agit d'une
ridicule et basses manoeuvres dont le
gouvernement a le secret
pierre joxe président du groupe
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale
les informations si j'en ai beaucoup
lionel jospin premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste
c'est pas vraiment les marchés d'armes
s'est pas soin c'est pas son goût voilà
alors je n'imagine pas je crois pas que
les français peuvent imaginer jospin
finançant le ps arrivé des ventes de
canard
lionel jospin premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste
je ne ferai aucune déclaration à ce
sujet tant que je n'aurai pas tous les
éléments en jeu
cure de jouvence à pékin en effet le
numéro un du régime monsieur dan xiao
ping 83 ans a décidé de passer la main
en traînant dans son départ
plusieurs autres octogénaires qui laisse
la place à une équipe rajeunie chargé de
concrétiser une politique économique
plus dynamique mais en fait tout le
monde s'accorde à dire que dans la
coulisse deng xiaoping va continuer à
diriger la manoeuvre après s'être
débarrassé de ses adversaires
conservateurs
jacques mirlin
les 1936 délégué du 13e congrès du parti
communiste chinois ont voté ce matin
comme un seul homme pas une voix n'a
manqué pour élire les 175 membres du
comité central et pourtant ce vote si
calme si bien ordonnée marqué la fin de
l'époque de deng xiaoping ce vieux
monsieur a tenu sa promesse à 83 ans il
passe la main en douceur sans crise sans
conflit arrivé au pouvoir après la mort
de mao tsé toung 1900 sont 17 il a
réussi à remettre la chine debout après
les folies de la révolution culturelle
en dix ans il a supprimé les communes
populaires rendu la terre aux paysans
réhabiliter la notion de profit et fait
appel aux capitaux étrangers
plusieurs fois menacé pour l'un
hardiesse de politique il a tenu bon
mais son entourage comme lui à béziers y
est les images enregistrées à
l'ouverture de ce congrès était
pathétique parce qu'elle signifiait
rajeunir la direction du parti était une
urgence absolue c'est donc maintenant
chose faite le nouvel homme fort du
régime
c'est ça aussi yang 69 ans un loukoum
mode en qui j'ai tout ressorti le
célèbre col mao à lui de jouer
maintenant mais il sait que dans les
coulisses deng xiaoping l'observera et
que si celui ci n'a plus de pouvoir
officielle il restera de son vivant une
autorité morale et politique
incontournable
en polynésie française les autorités
prolongent l'état d'urgence mais lève le
couvre-feu à l'occasion des fêtes de la
toussaint à papeete la capitale
une semaine après les incidents opposant
dockers et forces de l'ordre le
président des dockers a été placé en
garde à vue et en tout 44 personnes ont
été interpellées visiblement les
autorités ont décidé d'aller très vite
pour que tout rentre dans l'ordre mais
côté syndicats l'état de choc dissiper
on cherche la réplique dominique tirent
chacun d'entre nous le syndicat nos
dirigeants qu'ils éclairent ceux qui
nous gouvernent ici en métropole et nous
préserve de tout mal
la prière c'est ainsi que commence et
s'achève à tahiti chaque réunion
syndicale des dockers pendant ce temps à
l'assemblée territoriale le texte le
plus redouté sur la réforme du statut
des dockers étaient adoptées il prévoit
la création d'un service public concédé
à des entreprises privées service
minimum garanti en cas de grève en deux
mots la puissance des dockers anéanti
peu à peu l'opposition qui exigeait le
report du débat s'est retiré de la salle
laissant le champ libre aux affaires
locales nation le parti de gaston flosse
rendez vous discrets conversation
accords stratégiques dans les salons 24
heures de diplomatie de couloir pour
aboutir à cette image
tous les partis de l'opposition
en fait tout ce qui n'est pas et faire
réunis à la mairie par les
indépendantistes aux côtés de l'idf du
cdf des socialistes des partis locaux
l'heure est à la crise une partie de
bras de fer est engagé entre le
gouvernement territorial et les salles
du cac l'opposition a été ces points
mais s'inquiète de l' escalade du
conflit social moi je suis persuadé que
actuellement
les syndicats se regroupent et il peut
seulement y avoir une grève générale
parce que j'ai eu quelques échos là
dessus aussi donc oui et si hier la
majorité actuelle le gouvernement avait
accepté nos propositions je suis
persuadé que aujourd'hui dotées étaient
tous les revenus dans le calme et de
fait la menace est plus que sérieuse
hiro tefaarere et leader du jeune
syndicat affilié la cfdt tient à lui
seul les points stratégiques du
territoire nous contrôlons l'aéroport de
tahiti faa'a nous contrôlons les
hydrocarbures nous contrôlons les sites
du contrôle ont également les
principales mairies du territoire
dire que nous pouvons bloquer nous
pouvons bloquer dès que nous allons le
fait ça dépend pas de nous parce que
nous avons lancé un appel à la
constitution d'une intersyndicale pour
faire pression sur le territoire et
quelques heures plus tard
l'intersyndicale était constituée agents
de l'aéroport marc un secteur de
production d'énergie transport fait tt
fonction publique tous unis derrière les
terres position délicate au gouvernement
territorial
à mon avis ce ne sont pas des
revendications syndicales
alors il faut c'est à dire qu'elles sont
politiques pour vous mon avis sur une
question politique qu'il faut je crois
voir les choses comme elles sont
analysées convalescent je suis un homme
politique j'analyse la situation
politiquement tout d'abord et je crois
que
des objectifs sans des objectifs
politiques
aucun mot d'ordre de grève générale a
été lancé pour l'instant est plus que
jamais les tractations souterraines vont
reprendre
que nous réserve la semaine boursière
qui commence demain seuls les dieux de
la finance le sable jusqu'à présent pour
sa part monsieur alain juppé ministre du
budget interrogée sur m6 déclare que les
contacts entre les sept grands pays
industrialisés vont dans le bon sens que
leur réunion doit avoir lieu au plus
vite mais pas avant d'être sur la
boutique et pour la france cela signifie
dit monsieur juppé réduction du déficit
budgétaire américain et baisse des taux
d'intérêt allemands et japonais le
bateau panaméen a résonné hier par les
douaniers français au large du finistère
réserve bien des surprises non seulement
il contenait 150 tonnes d'armes qui
voguait vers une destination inconnue
mais outre en outre on a appris que le
bâtiment était piégé de telle façon qu
en cas d'arraisonnement ils pistent
aussitôt couler roland sicard
les trafiquants d'armes avaient pris
leurs précautions le bâtiment dans
lequel il convoyait plus de 150 tonnes
de matériels militaires étaient piégés
en montant à bord les douaniers ont
constaté que des charges explosives
avaient été disséminés en divers points
du navire objectif le bateau devait
pouvoir couler la première alerte du
travail de professionnels pourtant ce
dispositif n'a pas été utilisé les
convoyeurs d'armes n'ont peut être pas
eu la possibilité de le mettre en oeuvre
ils ont été interceptés au moment précis
où il était occupé à mettre à l'eau un
zodiac pour rejoindre clandestinement la
côte ce soir les enquêteurs ont la
certitude qu'ils avaient affaire à un
réseau de trafiquants internationaux
lesquels se trouvaient à bord ne portait
aucune marque d'origine les numéros de
toutes les armes avaient été
soigneusement lit mais seuls
l'interrogatoire des cinq hommes de
l'équipage permettra peut-être d'établir
à qui était destiné ce matériel de
guerre
est maintenant dans la série dans
l'intimité des grands de ce monde
charles d'angleterre et diana unis pour
le meilleur et pour le pire semble il
faut bien le dire se rapprocher en ce
moment plutôt de la deuxième hypothèse
imaginez que charles est allé tout seul
un mariage de famille en revanche sa
femme accepté de l'accompagner dans un
voyage en allemagne fédérale agnès
poigne
arrivé en provenance de londres le
prince et la princesse de galles ont été
accueillis cet après-midi à berlin ouest
par une foule enthousiaste 600
journalistes de la presse internationale
vont épier charles et diana pendant ce
séjour d'une semaine en allemagne
fédérale une seule question est sur
toutes les lèvres le couple princier va
t-il se réconcilier cela semble bien mal
parti ils ne sont pas vus depuis 38
jours charles passe son temps à méditer
en écosse diana à londres sort danse et
fait la fête et regarder cette image les
retrouvailles ne sont pas
particulièrement gaies pas un mot pas un
geste pas un regard
ce matin avant de quitter la
grande-bretagne lady diana n'a même pas
daigné accompagner son époux au mariage
de sa cousine
selon la presse britannique il est vrai
la mariée avait autrefois très bien
connu le prince
à berlin charles en tout cas a semblé
beaucoup plus à l'aise en compagnie de
l'armée britannique qu'avec sa jeune
épouse le malentendu royal ne semble pas
près de se dissiper
on verra bien le cirque en france est
démodé combien de fois at-on entendu
cette réflexion peut-être parce que
certains professionnels ont confondu
cirque et music hall ce n'est pas le cas
de la troupe ou plutôt je devrais dire
de la tribu des îles garraud qui
présente en ce moment à paris un
spectacle écrit équestre ou plus
exactement une comédie musicale dont les
acteurs sont les chevaux
nous n'avons plus qu'un bon spectacle
c'est un art de vivre on travaille des
choix parce qu'on adore les chevaux
c'est toute la vie on joue la musique
parce qu'on est toujours jouer cette
musique là et après tout le reste
puisqu'il fait l'atmosphère le père
disputa sais quelque chose car on ou
sept mois je pars du principe que tout
ce spectacle vivant c'est 1h30 2h ou 3h
devant des gens il faut quelque chose
parce si ça passe pas c'est raté
définitivement faux je suis à dépasser
important c'est l'émotion est ce que
l'on situe le travail avec les chevaux
niveau d'un arbre ce qui l'a toujours
été ce qu'il aurait dû toujours être bon
la richesse c'est aussi tout ce que
millénaire
e
je
quelque part on remet l'art équestre
niveau où il devrait être annie sportif
ni je parle c'est pas que du sport c'est
pas que du loisir c'est aussi de l'art
zougar aussi ça à leurs salaires frais
ni très souple comme ça mais en même
temps c'est sa grande taille et à sa
place
le sport maintenant avec d'abord un
rappel en formule 1 victoire de
l'autrichien berg air sur ferrari au
grand prix de tokyo et puis le marathon
de new york vient de se terminer comme
vous je vais découvrir le nom du
vainqueur et la course francis ma route
new york 22 mille personnes au
rendez-vous du canon du marathon 22
mille participants venus de tous les
coins du globe pas vraiment l'intimité
mais plutôt de quoi être intimidé en
fait intimidations promiscuité ce n'est
pas le problème du kenyan ibrahim
hyusein hyuseinov
parti devant loin devant les autres et à
29 ans il est le premier africain à
remporter le marathon de new york il
termine en deux heures 11 minutes et une
seconde derrière l'italien dit madonna
et deuxième fils hunger l'américain 3e
chez les dames victoire de l'anglais
priscilla wolch devant les françaises
françoise bonnet deuxième et je sculpte
troisième
voie il faut encore que je vous donne
les résultats du tiercé et du quarté +
qui vont s'inscrire sur votre écran
maintenant tiercé le rapport c'est 5347
francs 50 si vous avez joué le 8 le 10
et le 5 et le quarté + devrait
s'inscrire juste après le voici 8 10 5
13 27
1421 francs et 80 centimes
la météo maintenant les prévisions josé
pour demain bon bah oui même régime pour
tout le monde surtout de la douceur et
du soleil pratiquement partout tout ça
grâce à la présence d'un anticyclone sur
les îles briquettes britannique dont
c'est lui le grand responsable de ce
grand calme donc cet anticyclone
repousse fois ci repousse les nuages
vers l'est l'anticyclone est ici à peu
près résultats pour demain demain matin
les inévitables brouillard qui finiront
par se lever pour laisser place au
soleil de la bretagne voici au nord pas
de calais et jusqu'au massif central
donc grand soleil de la grisaille
toutefois des pyrénées à la vallée du
rhône jusqu'aux vosges et au jura où les
brunes seront particulièrement à se
dissiper côté température et bien sûr la
douceur avec 13 degrés à lille 16 degrés
à nantes 20 degrés à biarritz comme à
nice et un degré de plus à ajaccio et
demain lundi 2 novembre
eh bien ce sera une journée de
recueillement
merci j'osais simplement je voudrais
ajouter que le dernier journal sera tout
à l'heure présenté en fin de programme
par philippe gas aux alentours de 23
heures 35 et puis demain ici même à 20h
vous retrouverez henri sannier bonsoir
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 puis
bonne semaine et à la semaine prochaine